the cultural discourse around what
mental health is stopped squaring with
how we understand it as psychologists
and moved to a place where being
mentally healthy is equated with feeling
good or calm or relaxed or happy that
does not inform how we think about
mental health and psychology it's not a
good definition of mental health there
may be a kid who you know is confronted
by a tragedy something really awful
happens and it's extremely painful and
we would wish that it never happened but
if they're helped through it you end up
with teenagers who are philosophical and
and broad-minded in ways that you don't
see usually at that age being able to
accept distress and work one's way
through it
for teenagers in particular it's the
keys to the kingdom it is what lets them
move freely into the world